Ohhh...okay.
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica.
I just went through a frickin' endeavor.
Here's a little play-by-play of what I just underwent
trying to find, uh, the Seamoth fragments which don't exist anymore so...
Here's my adventure!
EPIC SWAN DIVE!
(opera of graceful screaming)
BOINK
Okay...
I don't know what that is, but I think they're after me!
Ooh hello..
(quietly) What are you?
Propulsion cannon? Hell yeah I'll take that!
There's a lot of fragments over here.
I might as well just grab up everything I can because one of the-
Oooooh.
(gasps) What's a filtration machine?
OOOOOOH WHAT'S A FILTRATION MACHINE!!!
(excited gasps)
Cause sounds cool!
Hehyahawwfuckoff OH NOO YOU DO NOT!
Huuuh no you do not.
I gotta FIND...
another GODDAMN FRAGMENT!
Seamoth fragment?
What?!
Oh, okay!
(laughing) What the hell is that?
Huh?
Oh!
OH!
That was a—what?!
That doesn't make any sense at all!
Oh, I'm so confused.
I had so many misconceptions about this episode!
(laughing) I thought I was gonna have to go by the ship!
Good! No Leviathan hunting for me!
[Leviathan hunting for Mark]
Dooh, hi! What are you doing in the shallow water?
Holy shit!
Hi, buddy!
Okay...
Well, while you're distracted, I'm gonna go around to the other side
and hopefully you—oh, you have a friend.
(laughing) I forgot you have a friend!
OH HE'S COMIN' RIGHT FOR ME!
OH SH- SHIT.
(nervous laughter)
Everything will be fine, everything will be fine
*Leviathan roaring*
EVERYTHING WILL BE NOT FINE!
*Leviathan roaring on its way to kill your ass*
OHHH, THAT IS THE SOUND OF SOMETHING THAT'S NOT FINE!
Whoa, I can't even get in bearings on where I am.
OF COURSE I COME OVER HERE. AT NIGHT.
WHOA, AND EVERYTHING IS HORRIBLE!
What is that? Ah goddammit.
Okay, then they- they did. They entirely changed it. There are no more Seamoth , uh... fragments!
There are just the Seamoth parts that I gotta find! Wherever they blew up!
Not particularly helpful in this endeavor that I ughuueur...
YEAH so that happened! Um.
I came outta that with a little more knowledge though
because now I know that the Seamoth is only found
from exploded pieces of the Seamoth which, um...
I should've realized because that's how you get the Cyclops now. You just find, uh, the various
pieces of the Cyclops, or maybe that was how it was before and I just don't remember, ah
but the Seamoth was definitely not that way
it was: FIND THE FRAGMENTS, GO HAVE FUN, LIVE YOUR GODDAMN LIFE!
But now we have to deal with other things so
In other news- ohh shit I walked into a wasp nest
Holy shiieiieit
In OTHER news,
I've got a nnnnumber of new things that I have to show you guys, um,
number one (1): I found the fragments for the Scanner Room,
uh there's this new device called a "Rebreather" that may not be new but I've just never used it.
Uh... I got the Moonpool and a various number of other things that I think I-
OH I FOUND THE FILTRATION THING!
You guys probably saw that in my little play-by-play
but the filtration system means that I-
Ooh that don't look fun.
I won't have to deal-HHHGG with taking airsacs outta the environment
and then SQUEEZING the water out of them with my bare hands, so that's good.
So what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna head back
and I'm gonna try to find another wreckage where
there could possibly be -
Seamoth?
I- Is that..? *gasp* That iiiis
OOOOOH- that's a Seamoth fragment - okay cool!
WELL THAT WAS CONVENIENT.
THAT SURE DID- oww shit, goddammit fuck you.
What the fuck- EUGHH- What're you ya pulsating weirdo?
Ok so that was fortunate, now I only need one more to be able to make the Seamoth
and so that one should be in this general area - ah okay.
This is the- I think this is the- no this is different.
Ooh this is a different one, okay.
So if I look around here, hopefully- what is you?
Propulsion Cannon? Ah I think I need one of you anyway.
Yeah there we go, I got the Propulsion Cannon!
Hot tits - Look at me!
Okay I don't need that-
Okay so...
Now that I have that, then in this general area there should be another, uh, Seamoth fragment around here
and then I'll finally be able to make the Seamoth.
I'll give Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall a JOB because they've been little freeloaders
but that's ok, I love 'em nonetheless.
AND THEN I'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE DO WITH EVERYTHING ELSE THAT I GOT!
And I'll be able to go around the world and not have to rely on THIS stupid piece of shit
Which, admittedly is nice to have
But goddammit, is it a pain in the ass.
Oh. Oh. OH. OH! OH!!
Is that- please tell me that's not just metal- (gasps)
THAT'S A SEAMOTH!
(sing songy) OOOOH I GOOOT IIIIT! I GOOOOOOOT IT
YES! Oooh that is terrifying-
Ho-ho-hOLY shit!
That's less terrifying, that's more cool all of a sudden.
Okay! But I got what I needed
so I have that.
I have a lot of new blueprints.
I'm gonna make my way back to my main base
and we're gonna have a good ol' time assembling a whole bunch of materials
because I have ALSO
been very dutiful to you guys, and I have farmed up everything that I need,
hopefully,
to be able to do these things! So-
Oh, shit.
I did not know that I was going that way.
Okay, so I'm gonna be right back once I get back to my main base.
Not... my... other place.
Ahh, home sweet home.
So I've made a few expansions, mostly just, uh,
putting out more foundations for everything else that I'm gonna need.
Uh, but my next step is gonna be the mobile, uh...
Actually, not the Moonpool just yet,
because, I'm pretty sure
that I'm gonna need other things besides the Moonpool as a priority.
I'm gonna prioritize new things, before I'm gonna prioritize things that I have already gotten,
and that includes the Seamoth, unfortunately.
But...
That does mean that I have a lot more opportunites
to make some pretty cool things.
I'm actually pretty close to getting the Cyclops, I just need to find, a few more broken pieces here and there.
So!
In the endeavour of getting new things for you guys...
Oh, I don't know what that is, but a walt-
Water filtration machine!
That sounds good!
I can build that right now!
Only two titanium, that's...
that's literally awesome!
How do I make that- OOHH!
OOOHH!
OOOH!
OOOOOOOOH!!
Ooh, do I want everything in this main room?
It would be pretty cool.
Alright I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna say I'm not gonna go around this way so...
*gasps* I can't believe that only took two Titanium!
(fascinated Mark sounds)
"Use filtration machine?"
What do I gotta do?
How do I do it?
What do I do?
What?
Oh, it's already doin' it!
Oh, it looks like a water dispenser from a goddamn gym.
*giggle*
Okay
So...
Apparently, I- I suppose I could just...
put things in it, but I don't have that...
Okay, I'm gonna let this do its thing,
um,
maybe I'm gonna put another one in here somewhere.
Maybe just to have kind of two water filtration machines.
I mean, what's the harm? They only take two Titanium,
might as well make some more.
Oh-ho-ho!
It kind of made it a little crowded in here.
I probably, I probably should put these in another room just because I have
this giant-ass thing in the middle of my goddamn living room
And I need these over here.
But this is so cool!
I can just make water whenever I want!
Whenever I want...
Whenever I want!
I'll just make this the water room, holy shit.
I've never had a whole room dedicated to one purpose like this... *Mark chuckles*
but, yeah, I'll make it a water room!
Hot damn!
Look at that!
Oh god, it's sucking my power!
OH NO!
MY POWER!
My bio-reactor isn't good enough for this shit.
Okay, but that's fine.
I'll get a nuclear reactor down the road, but,
uh, that's only one of the things that I wanted to show you.
The other thing is...
I need to... uh...
I'll get the names in just a second!
I will get the names.
Um, I needed to get one of those, because I need to make a Wiring Kit...
And then, I can make
this piece of equipment called a "Rebreather!"
It doesn't even have a texture!
It's a big ol' question mark.
But with the Rebreather,
Hopefully...
Equip?
Equip with- equip where...?
I don't know...!
What do you...
What do you want with me?!
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?!
I think that's where that would go, isn't it?
Yeah! Okay!
'Cause I don't need the radiation helmet unless I'm actually nearby the thing,
so I can put my...
radiation stuff...
I'm gonna build a few more lockers here real quick...
Uh, because I need to put names on the walls anywaaaay.
So I neeeEEEED...
Okay, so the first one goes to... "Brandi Gaulthier," "Brandi G"
Uh, who says- who asks if I had to look up the names of my children, and no I did not!
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall are in my heart forever!
I would never forget them probably.
Uh, and the next one goes to "MaeJuan," uh, who said that I'm going crazy! From isolation!
I'd like you to try to prove it, if you can!
There's not enough evidence out there on the internet to say otherwise.
Uh the next one goes to "Marki's Moo," Ma- "Marki's Mo," uh...
who said it sucks that the old game got deleted but there's a new beginning to it, you know "All things
happen for a reason," even though it's just a game and it's Subnautica.
I think the reason was I needed to upgrade everything, but thank you nonetheless.
And the last one goes to "MiniButter" who had a whooooole bunch of advice.
Thank you very much for, uh, shouting out and giving advice on placement on where I needed to put my base.
So the other thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna deconstruct two (2) of these because holy shit.
All of my power is gone.
Can I- Can I deconstruct this please, thank you?
I mean...
A-As much as I would love to have these water filtration systems, I kinda fudged up on not being able to
get what I needed. So.
The names are on the lockers and now, uh, the next step is I need to construct...
Oh shiiiiiiiit, I need enameled glass.
(quiet frustration) Ffffffffuuuuuuuuck.
Let's see I got... two glaaaaaass- I'll put that in thereeeee.
I neeeeeeeed lubricant and a power cell.
(in some odd accent) Where am I going to get power cell?
Oh ya I've got the power cell right here, Brandi's got them.
Okay so if I take this up, up, up, up , up, up, and up!...
to..
Oh am I- oh I was using it- UP!...
to Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshal, they should be able to help me with what I need.
Hi boys! Sorry- whoa shit. Sorry- little drunk. Didn't mean to come here drunk again. Alright.
Boink.
There we go!
SEAMOTH, BABY! And I can't name it yet but at least I'll have it!
OHHHH!
Why do you keep building it up in the sky like that?
It's cool though! You know- you boys do your thing. I like how it's in the shadow of the moon.
Or whatever that is.
Hello! Oh my baby. It's been so long.
How're you doing?
How you doin'.
Okay, so anyway.
*computerized voice: Welcome aboard captain.*
(mocking computer voice) "Welcome aboard." Hello.
You're not quite the "U.S.S. F**k A Duck", and I may n- make a new name out of it.
Maybe you guys can help me name the new ship once I get the, uh... the umm... Moonpool accessed again.
But I won't be able to do that just yet because I need to do other things first, so with this,
I can take the Seamoth and I can go make the creatures over here nibble on my hull until they lose their teeth.
So... be right back once again!
Here, bite my butt.
Bite my butt baby.
Bite my butt baby boo.
Ha-bonk.
Oh no... did you lose "undt" tooth? Oh no...
Okay, so I FINALLY got it. It wasted an ENORMOUS amount of power on my Seamoth but I finally got it.
I had to go- I could only get like one (1) from every Stalker, so I had to go around and find enough
Stalkers to be able to get what I need, but I do have it.
So I'm gonna make some glass, and then I'm gonna make some enameled glass-
I think I only need two (2)?
Do I need two (2)? I have no idea.
(quietly) Uh... where was it? Where the hell- there it is.
Oh I only needed one (1). Oh that's convenient!
I need computer chips though.
That was the thing that I needed more of, okay.
So I need to make enameled glass. I'll go ahead and make two (2) cause I know there's probably something
else that need enameled glass. I think the Cyclops needs A LOT of enameled glass and I don't have
enough for it, but I'm not gonna farm that up right now because I don't have time to waste for that!
And I'm about to run out of power.
Holy shit.
Goddammit.
Oh.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you!!
Th-thank you! "Big filtered Water." Me likey "Big filtered water!"
Well, I'll take some of that thank you.
Okay so I got that, I got the titanium and now I just need the computer chips, but I need enough power to be able
to do that. Goddammit.
(sing-songy) Fuuuuuuuuuuck meeeeeeee. Never enouuuuuugh.
Fuck, I can't even open it.
Oh good, it's turning into daytime, okay that's good.
Alright so I need... computer chips, which require silver ore-
OH NOOOOOO
I don't think I have sil- awww I'm- I only have one (1).
(frustrated Mark noises)
Ahhhh shit. I gotta go get...
I gotta go get silver ore.
Hurray for me!
I'm not gonna waste my Seamoth's energy on that. I'm gonna go here.
I- I- I know I just need to go down here and I need to get all the things and the things and do the things to the
things.
OOOOHHHHHHHH, IT'S A NEVER ENDING CYCLE OF NEEEEW STUUUUFF.
Man, I wish I was cheating. (chuckling)
But I'm not gonna.
I have integrity.
There we go.
Oh that all I need? I think that might be all I need.
But I might as well get some more... while I'm here.
Never know when you're gonna need more batteries.
OOOOOH YES. Please and thank you.
Okay I think I got enough silver. I got really lucky on that one so I didn't have to go around very much.
HOT DAMN.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna make these computer chips and then we're gonna make the Scanner Room
and then after an off-shoot of that we're gonna make the Moonpool, but I'm not gonna worry about that right now
because I need table coral which I have in here.
Okay.
And then we make two (2) of these, and we'll have exactly what we need.
Boinkity boinkity boink- I'm glad I didn't do that in the wrong order. I think that's gonna be enough.
Nope, need some titanium but I got plenty of that- boink boink boink.
ANNNNNND
THAT'S ALL SHE WROTE.
Ohhhhh I think this might be it. Okay this is good.
Now lemme get closer here.
Okay.
So.
We need a Scanner Room.
Oh what the frick-a-dick.
What was that?
How does that- waaaait a minute.
Why is that-?
Why's that being all weird?
Wha-what?
Connect!
What the- what the hell is it doin'?!
Connect to my goddamn base, why don'tcha?!
Is it because I don't have, like-
What?
That doesn't- uh- I- Ohhh my god this one is... nooooot very good on the placement.
What the fuck is happening?
Why won't this place exactly?
IIIII have no idea
I guess... I guess beggars can't be choosers here we go!
Holy shit that was hard to place, but I got it! It's over the precipice but that's good?
(spooky raspy voice?) I guess.
Let's go find out what it is. Cause I have not seen this yet.
Alright,
making our downtown,
walking fast,
moving past,
and I'm homebound.
Alright we do we got?
What do we have here?
*Computer voice: Caution: calorie deficiency detected.*
Ooooooh.
"Salt deposit," "quartz," "titanium," "lithium," "lead?"
OHHHHHHH THAT'S COOL!
(happy gasps)
That's cooooool.
That's coooOOOOOL.
THAT'S COOOOOOOL.
I don't know what any of this d- OHHH.
OHHHHHHHHH.
OH
Oh my god I just hit it.
WHOA.
LOOKIT THIS.
Whaaaaaaaat!?
(excited Markimoo noises)
I got my own camera!
Ooooh and it spots lithium.
I wonder what this means, can I like-?
Can I grab it with- it's just a camera right? I- It wouldn't be able to grab it.
Wha- (gasp)
It's got two (2) cameras.
OHHHHHHHH SHIIIIIIIIIIT
What the fuck that's so cool!
Oh that's so cool!
How do I get out of it though? How do I get out of it?
Ah shit.
Uh.
Okay there we go, just gotta hit "escape." Oh that's so cool!
"Metal salvage." It can- oh my god!
This is -this would be incredibly useful, holy shit.
Okay, so the scanner room is here.
And I can even give it upgrade modules which, I believe you can increase its range... uh, speed, and HUDs.
So all these are easy upgrades beause they only take computer chips.
So I should be able to do that! Okay!
With that, I'm gonna end this episode here because I have been playing this for a while, but that's how it
always goes whenever I play Subnautica, so.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you think of this and what I should do in the next episode in the comments below,
and thanks again.
And as always, I will see you... in the next video.
Bye bye!
*Crazy La Paint outro*
(1st video in top left) Oh! What the hell?!
Where'd you come from?  You back up there buddy!
Okay...
So...
WhaaAAAA the he-!?!?
*in panic* GET AWAY FROM-
(screaming mark gibberish)
(2nd video on bottom left) Oh god!
*reading from text* The rose was poisoned!  It courses through Samanthera's body...  *Mark's added bit* Samanthera explodes!
HURK!
*boom sound*
OH GAWD!
do do do doooo....